this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name's
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're here with
author and environmental lawyer robert f
kennedy jr whose new podcast can be
found at anchor
dot fm slash rfk jr or wherever you
listen to podcasts
robert thank you for joining us today
thanks for having me i thought we would
start by answering some questions here
our first one is from jessica what is
our biggest
environmental problem deforestation air
pollution global warming
water pollution natural resource
depletion
is it too late to fix it
it's an expansive question right so i
mean yeah to sum it up what's our
biggest environmental problem and is it
too late to fix it
let me explain my voice because your
audience
may not be used to hearing me i i use a
very strong voice i was 42 years old
and then i got a disease called
spasmodic dystonia
it makes my voice tremble like this and
particularly when i first start talking
it trembles
usually it gets better or people get
used to it as i talk so
i just kind of want to get that out of
the way so people you know
aren't wondering about it to me the
thing that
i think is most disturbing is the um
the extinctions of easies yeah yeah and
you know that even when i was a kid i
was and i heard about the dodo bird i
was like
you know just very disturbed about that
and felt like i you know almost a sense
of betrayal like how could people
let a species like sing yeah and you
know having this sense of that
we don't really have the
it's morally wrong to destroy something
that you cannot
create or that you cannot recreate and
um
you know now we're in the middle because
of
um you know because of human uh
factors we are now in the middle of the
biggest mass extinction
in history yeah uh climate change is
part of that
and uh and population is a factor too
but
you know those things um
in some cases well and you ask the
question is can we reverse it
um we can do our best to mitigate it
right but at this point you know our
children are not going to have the same
opportunities no matter what we do at
this point for dignity and enrichment
and good
health as as we had yeah
and that you know is a tragic and it's a
moral issue
yeah yeah and the question is you know
what can we do
it's really uh you know we're involved
in a in a war
and it's a war against mainly you know
most of these problems are the cause of
of large corporations who are
politically powerful
who are you know who are enmeshed
invested in this
um in consumerism and in bad behavior
right who are not looking out for
humanity but
because of the nature of our laws with
their incentive eyes to
um to make decisions that enrich
themselves by impoverishing the rest of
us
right it's at the detriment of other
people it's incredibly selfish yeah ryan
and i certainly aren't against
consumption
and we all consume some stuff right and
people
often mistake us for ascetics or some
sort of monks or something like that no
we
we try to live well within society and
i think part of that has to do with
being intentional but also being
intentional about not harming
other people which actually leads me to
a question that izzy has here
izzy says at what point is it dangerous
to keep saying there are no
should so ryan and i often talk about
you know there are no shoulds what we
really mean by that is
we often overly moralize everything you
know we'll tell people you shouldn't eat
carbs after 3 p.m or something
you see it on commercials and podcasts
and and you sort of these internet
experts telling us we should do this you
shouldn't do that you should do this
and most of them are just opinions you
could do this or you
you don't have to do this or whatever
but of course there is
morality in life and there are some
shoulds you ryan you should not kidnap
my daughter
i should not that is correct um well i
mean
could you even take it i don't know so
you're saying there are some shirts
because i'm saying you could rephrase
that and say something like
um ryan i prefer you not to kidnap my
daughter
because that would really hurt our
family and that it really seems immoral
i prefer you not do that but i guess
that should
that still is kind of a should yeah i
mean when we're talking i mean this is
all
it gets complicated with language we
talk about things as good or bad
should or shouldn't that we often overly
moralize
things i want to avoid becoming you know
fully nihilistic and just saying well
nothing matters at all there is no moral
good or bad
that's not what we're talking about here
to continue izzy's question you want to
read the rest of it ryan sure it says
i get caught up in trying to fight for
environmental justice but worry
i'm crossing the line i don't want to
tell anyone how to live their life
but i'm unwilling to let go of my
attachment to caring for the earth
so i have a so i have strong opinions
about what people
shouldn't do environmentalism is an idea
that i cannot back down from
compromise on or see from both sides
i think this is a problem too when we're
not willing to even look at the other
side
and bobby it seems to me that what you
do well is
you are able to see both sides and even
consider even the side of the
corporation if someone's being immoral
you're able to even see it from their
point of view and you can quickly
cast judgment on that person or or
entity but can we talk a little bit
about this because
it is a moral quandary i try to stay
away from telling people how they should
live their lives
and i really i i hope i don't do that
yeah you know and that's not
i think i believe in personal liberties
and that people should make their own
choices
and i don't think the big
driver of environmental destruction is
you can change you with individual
choices and i was on a board for many
years with the
ceo of rockner and gamble and he showed
me data they have data going back
consumer data going back about more than
a century
and what he showed me is that people
um will there's a steady
number of people who will change their
purchasing behavior because of moral
appeals
and other words it's true you know if
you do this
if you buy this it's better for society
and it never gets more than eight
percent of the public
ever you can change people's behavior by
saying it's good for your
health oh it's individually good for me
but people are gonna buy essentially the
cheapest thing
most of the people to me what you guys
do is really and i've seen your
you know your video and i think it's
really important but it's more important
for
um it's more important because it's
important
as i said for us as individuals and for
our peace of mind that we live moral
lives and that we live connected lives
and
we live um
mindfully and but
you know i remember my a lot of my
attitudes
are came out in the 1960s it was an
advertisement on tv it was the biggest
psa
ever in history and it showed somebody
throwing some garbage
out of the window of a car yes there was
an indian standing on the road who was
crying
right and that it got 500 million
dollars of
free psa time wow it was made by a group
called
keep america beautiful right and people
thought that was an environmental group
but it wasn't
it was a coalition of gas bottle
manufacturers and aluminum can
manufacturers
whose principal objective was to fight
bottle bills from being passed in the 50
states
wow oh it was trying to tell american
consumers
the reason we have garbage is because
you guys are slobs
it's not because the corporations aren't
paying for a litter disposal
right and in the united states the
the highest altitude landmark on the
east coast north north america
is the fresh-killed landfill okay and
the reason and they don't have landfills
like that in europe
why because in europe
garbage disposal is not paid for by the
taxpayer
in our country garbage disposal is
subsidized by the taxpayer
and so amazon will send you a credit
card
in a shoe box right as it can blast at
the outside of that shoe box with
advertising oh it becomes an advertising
vehicle for them and there's no
cost to them from doing that right
in europe if you people who send out
companies that send out packaging
have to weigh it and measure it and then
they have to recover it
and anything they don't recover they
have to pay for
and as a result of that when you get a
cd in europe it comes in cellophane
when you get a credit card it comes in a
tiny little envelope
it's like you sent that the company that
sent that to you has to pay for the
disposal and that goes to his bottom
line
yeah but if you don't you know and you
don't get these big packages that are
filled with little uh styrofoam peanuts
right that are
with some tiny little item in it that
drives me crazy when i get a box that is
just
it's it's it's nothing you know it's
it's a little timer like
this and it's it's a it's a five-gallon
box filled with
styrofoam i thought it was laziness i
didn't realize it was intentional for
advertising that's why
but it's incentivizing good behavior if
the government is saying to you
there is no cause to you for you putting
garbage
and packaging into the stream of
commerce
if you're in europe and you're a
manufacturer and you put packaging into
the stream of commerce you have to
recover
you have to show that it's recycled or
recovered or you pay for it
and because of that you were
incentivized to not create packaging so
and to me the way that you change and
this goes back to what i said originally
about procter and gamble the way that
you change
change behavior is not through appealing
to people's morality
yeah so so it's not back to what izzy is
saying you shouldn't do this because
it's not really helpful it doesn't help
and it can only only eight percent of
people and usually only three percent
will
respond to those appeals so at least 92
percent of people are checking out
the media listen to you so what you do
is you incentivize good behavior yes
integrating by rationalizing the
marketplace by saying
you can make money by doing good things
rather than
you you know we're going to allow you to
make money by doing bad things by
flooding the
nation with garbage so for example
if you know if we had a carbon tax
people then would figure out we would
innovate
new ways and and they did this in the
state of california
which is why california uses
less energy about 8 000 kilowatts
whereas the national use about 12
000 kilowatts per person per household
okay
the reason for that is that california
changed the laws to incentivize good
behavior and to punish bad behavior a
true free market
should that's what it should do it
should incentivize good but everybody's
saying
you can use carbon if you want but if
you do you're going to pay for it
because it's hurting other people and
we're also
not going to subsidize it right we're
not going to
we're not going to allow you to
externalize your cost
through pollution if you pollute you're
welcome to pollute
but if you do it you're going to pay a
price for it
and there's certain pollution we're not
going to allow which is toxic
right but if you do other pollution if
you put carbon
into the stream of car into the public
area into the public commons
if you put ozone and particulates or
these other pollutants
we're going to charge you and that is
going to incentivize you
to switch to more efficient forms
of creating energy and creating products
and that's really what we want to do
it's not to tell everybody don't buy a
new car
right tell the manufacturers you cannot
build a car
unless it you know we're going to charge
you we're going to incentivize you to
build cars
that have the lowest energy consumption
that it's possible
and the more that you do that the more
money you're going to make so you can
it's a marketplace that allows people to
make money
by doing good things rather than telling
you that
you can make money by doing bad things
to your neighbor
ultimately it's the carrot and the stick
and what you're saying is the carrot is
so much more effective at least for the
vast majority
of the population nobody likes a busy
body and nobody likes a nag
right and nobody wants to be told you
know you can't behave this way because
you're hurting the planet and i don't do
that to people
and in fact it makes me want to do the
opposite quite often if someone tells me
you shouldn't do that
yeah i almost want to do it out of spite
right you know it's like well what do
you mean i'm going to go out and just
turn my car on for a while just to
you know piss this person off of course
i'm not actually going to do that
but there's something in the the in
humanity that makes us say whoa don't
tell me what to do right leave me alone
but if you incentivize
me to do something i'm much more likely
to do it
yeah maybe we do a reverse psychology
marketing plan of uh you should litter
okay you used to be in the state of
california
if you wanted to build a power plant
you would go to the public service
commission utility wood and say
look there's a demand for this energy
and i'm going to build a power plant
here's how much it's going to cause i'm
going to build a coal burning power
plant
here's how much it's going to cost and
here's how much the rates
are going to rise because of that and
we're going to
we're going to build that plan for 100
million dollars let's say yeah
and we want our board our shareholders
to make 12
interest on that and if the psa
said i was okay if you were able to
convince them then you would build that
power plant you would have 100 million
into it
and the cause of that plan is now
integrated
into the rate base and your shareholders
are making 12
a year on that investment and
what we did in the late 70s and early
80s
we changed the california rule to say
that um
we are going to incentivize you
to build power plants that don't
use carbon or to make expenditures that
don't use carbon
oh for 100 million dollars
you can go the power company can go into
20 million ohms and change out the old
light bulbs
and put in a new one it can go and buy
your old refrigerator
and put in one that used two percent of
the energy
wow and for that 100 million
it can create five times as much energy
as if they built a new power plant wow
and they can make
the twelve percent you're incentivizing
them to do
something that is much better for
society right
than just folk you're giving people the
power
to do well by doing good yes right
rather than telling them there's one way
to do this and it's by burning more coal
and that's you know right now if we
actually told people
you're going to pay the trooper cause of
that goal which is
you build a coal plant you're acidifying
virtually every lake in the adirondacks
and in the appalachian chain from
georgia to northern quebec
you are on the coal plants in this
country now cause about 375 million
dollars a year
in lung damage in health care costs
in the states that have coal the unlike
kentucky and
west virginia the federal government
pays for
extra pavement they have to put 12
inches of payment to support the coal
trucks on the highways oh wow
we pay those costs sure wow you have
every freshwater fish in america now has
mercury in its flesh
there's a healthcare clause for that as
well yeah
if you told those coal plants you have
to internalize those costs
coal instead of costing five cents a
kilowatt hour
would cost 50 cents a kilowatt hour and
nobody would be buying coal power
it just wouldn't make sense financially
it wouldn't make sense if you force them
to internalize the cost so it's really a
market failure the market is not telling
them
you have to pay the true cost of
bringing that product to market which
includes the cost of cleaning up after
yourself which was a lesson we were all
supposed to have learned in kindergarten
right we are incentivizing them to
behave badly
and in fact you know there's a it was
that
the president or the ceo of duke energy
which is one of the biggest cult fleets
in the world
in the country i think it's the largest
coal burning power plant
the coal burning fleet and the country
of power plants
of generating facilities he had kids he
was in north carolina
he saw what it was doing to the waters
he saw how bad it was for the country
and he went to congress and said you
need to change the rules to force us to
internalize the cost because then i can
close all my coal plants and i can
switch to something much better
and congress the coal industry blocked
them oh my god
wow what what because he said i
am killing i'm destroying the planet and
destroying the life that my kids are
operating these plants but
i can't close them on my own
because my shareholders were to sue me
his responsibility as a ceo
is to maximize shareholder value right
yeah he has a fiduciary responsibility
and that's what he that's what these
companies
well you know it's not their fault that
they're immoral
it's that we have created rules
and incentivize them to to act that way
every for example if you see
you know after katrina after hurricane
katrina is a walmart
bringing bottles of water down to the
katrina victims
and they're not they're not doing that
to be good guys right
they're doing it because the the um
the optics of them doing that
make walmart look good and we make more
people shop there
which increase shareholder value right
if they were actually doing it just to
be good guys
any of their shareholders could sue them
for wasting corporate assets
corporations are not allowed to act
altruistically
they're not allowed to act
philanthropically
there's a few exceptions to that right b
corporations and
well if if you re if you organize the
company differently but how many
companies are b corporations
no no i don't think so and so yeah you
can do it that way but that's not
how most of them are organized most of
them are organized according to
you know that virtually everything on
the dow jones
is organized so that shareholders know
that the corporation
is acting in basically in their
short-term economic interests
right and what we're doing is we're
incentivizing ceos of
people like i'm like the ceo of duke
he has to wake up every morning and say
you know
am i going to make decisions today that
are good for humanity
or am i going to make decisions that are
good for my shareholders
yeah because those two things are not
the same right and for him
they are mutually exclusive yeah and
what you want to do
is you want to create a mark you can
design markets any way you want
you want to design markets to
rationalize them so that people
are able to make money by doing good
things for humanity
rather than forcing them to like you're
forcing him to
make money by destroying people in the
planet well i want to talk to you about
some of the true
costs of things because it's fascinating
when you pick up an object from a shelf
and you see the price tag on the thing
that's the price of the thing but the
true cost goes well beyond the price tag
is of course the environmental cost of
producing the thing or trashing the
thing but also ryan and i often talk
about
from a minimalist perspective it's yeah
the the storage space for the thing and
so we need to have larger homes than
ever before to keep all of our things
and when our
homes are overflowing putting our
garages and basements and then
the storage locker industry you know
there's more storage facilities than
there are corporate starbucks
and so there are all these places where
we're holding on to all these things and
the true
cost is unbelievable but when we think
about the environment
we often pretend as though the
environment and humans are sort of
standing in separate corners of the room
there's like an external environment we
don't think about what it does to our
internal environment so we have a
question here from our friend chris
kelly a former podcast guest
who uh who has a question about about
this yeah uh
he wrote in can you get rfk to talk
about
our leap first look later approach to
environmental chemicals
the quintessential example is bpa now we
have bps bpf
bpb bpaf they all have similar
properties but hey
they're bpa-free that's a marketing ploy
right you see all this all the time
bpa free right
and they just change one molecule on it
right and they say the same thing
right yeah that's equally harmful that's
the same with bfoa
and you know the problem is uh
you know this is what rachel carson
pointed out in 1961 when she wrote
silent spring and she told americans for
the first time these chemicals are
imposing hidden cause on you because
nobody understood that
and like you know the chemists
were heroes a were the people from
dupont and dao and these other companies
who had won world war
ii they had created you know ddt and
killed the mosquitoes and now
it won the war against the nazis and now
we are going to win the war against the
bugs
and what she said is wait a second
you're going to kill the bug
you're going to kill all the birds too
and you're going to kill your out pets
and you're going to give cancer to your
children
and you know these are all the hidden
costs of these chemicals
do we know this early on i suspect there
wasn't a whole lot of knowledge
and even today your average person
nobody knew when she wrote that book she
was a very interesting woman i met her
at my house
in 1962 my uncle you know
monsanto was trying to destroy her she
never spoke out to defend herself
because she was dying of cancer at the
time but my uncle i'm very proud of
president kennedy went to her aid and
his own um
department of agriculture was leading i
mean the people who were raiding against
her were
incredible the american medical
association was
like trying to kill her because they
they were saying you know they're always
on the side of big chemicals and big
companies and they were saying ddt is
important because it kills mosquitoes
and malaria is a big health threat
yeah um you had sports illustrated doing
an editorial against their time magazine
life magazine
you had which are all kind of you know
at that point all tied in with the war
machine and the cia and
you had um the american garden club
coming out against her so she was being
attacked from every direction
she was as you know this extraordinary
woman she was a marine biologist
brilliant marine biology she written two
other bestsellers before
she didn't see the ocean until she was
22 years old
she was born in kind of the backwoods of
pennsylvania
and she was a very fluid eloquent writer
and she was able to translate science
into something that the lay person could
read
she wrote this book in 1961 silent
spring that became the biggest
bestseller in history
and she was attacked monsanto put
millions and millions into creating
public relations
agencies and and trying to destroy her
reputation my
uncle breaking with its own department
of agriculture created
and led by jerome wisner who was a
science advisor who created this
um this independent group of scientists
read through her book
and to check it for factual accuracy
yeah and you know she was being told you
know like people are today that it's
full of misinformation chemical
misinformation and
you're um you're lying to the public and
you're endangering the public et cetera
and um and that committee
vindicated her on every principle point
that she made in that book
and she died a couple of years later
in 1976 we passed a law called task or
there's a toxic substance control act
by then the by the time we passed it the
um the chemical industry had gotten
control of congress and they put
provisions and that statute
that would make it almost impossible to
enforce
and that's what happened so there since
and 85
000 new chemicals have come on the
market
many of them associated with these
consumer products
you guys are so deeply concerned about
um
in that time only 200 of those chemicals
have ever been tested so we have a
hundred thousand chemicals basically
that are closed yeah
and and only five of them have been
banned oh my god
and the way that it works is that epa
has no budget to test the chemicals
so and the chemicals the way the act
works
is a chemical is innocent until it's
proven guilty
and so and the company is in charge of
conducting the test
and what the company does is the company
you know hires these funny
scientists what they call them by
astitudes
create these you know these phony um
studies that show that it's safe the
endpoint is already there before they do
the
study yes find us a way to get to this
endpoint basis exactly
right and so and so i i i'm someone who
has really bad
chemical sensitivities and so i can't go
into a room that's been freshly painted
for example
and i'm sure a lot of that has to do
with some different pharmaceutical
interventions and i'm sure we can even
talk about the pharmaceutical industry
at some point today or during the
maximal
but the all of these chemicals what's
really fascinating about this
is is i think the average person even
today
like they hear bpa they're like i don't
i don't even know what that is and i'm
hearing about like all the chemicals in
drinking water consumer reports just did
this
study where you know my favorite
drinking water topo chico had
like 10 times the quote acceptable level
of
pufas or whatever whatever the acronym
is
for chemicals and so we we have all of
these chemicals entering our bodies
every day whether we're breathing it
or we're ingesting it and we don't even
know
what's going into us and it's no wonder
that we're we're so sick
yeah i mean the
our children are now kind of walking
around in a
just this witch's brew of toxic
chemicals
and we've never there's never been a
generation raised with these kind of
assaults on our ecosystem and they're
cumulative we know that
your your you know the human biome the
human immune system
it's designed to take a lot of stress if
it's being stressed
every day and your mitochondrial and all
of these
and different cell structures are under
consonant salt
from emfs from you know fluoride in the
water
from um from the pesticides in your food
and chemical residues everywhere and
where you're breathing
and mold there's no rest from it yeah
and
you know so here's what we've had an
explosion
of um of chronic disease
yes that has made our children this
generation of children
the second generation in history it's
unbelievable and there's three
categories essentially of chronic
disease that we see now are epidemic one
is neurodevelopmental diseases so
add adhd speech delay language late
ticks tourette syndrome narcolepsy
um asd autism is typical autism has gone
from one in ten thousand in my
generation to one in every 34
in my children's generation yeah you
don't see any people who
are appreciably elderly ryan and i are
40 this year
who are above 40. you do not see
i have never in my life seen somebody
with full-blown autism my age
and i was raised on the spear tip of the
movement for intellectual disabilities
my family started special olympics
i worked for 200 hours when i was a kid
and while i say
home for the [ __ ] we never saw
people like this we never saw him by
full-blown autism
what i mean is non-verbal non-toilet
train
screaming stimming toe walking
um agonizing gut aches
you don't see men my age walking around
with football helmets and diapers
at the local mall i have never seen
anybody like that and yet at my kids age
you know it's one in every 34 kids
that's one category neurodevelopmental
allergic disease and most of these
appeared in 1989 in fact congress said
the epa tell us what year the epidemic
in autism
and they came back and said 1989 it's a
red line well um
and also that year food allergies
peanut allergy i never knew it i have
like 70 first cousins 11 brothers and
sisters
i never knew anybody with a peanut
allergy and you had a lot of kennedy's
out there
yeah a lot of them no it doesn't like
the peanut
allergy yeah i remember that blowing up
and it's like yeah where did it come
from
yeah and why aren't why isn't tony fauci
asking that question he's the head of
allergic
and you know i don't mean diseases he's
not asking
we know where it's coming from it's
coming from these chemical exposures and
we know specifically which ones but
you also had anaphylaxis you had eczema
up here that year
you had all these autoimmune issues
asthma
you know which was around but it
exploded right and you
um and so we have all those diseases
and then the autoimmune disease which is
the biggest category which is rheumatoid
arthritis you have an
ib you it's hard to find anybody prior
to 1989 that had those diseases
afterward they're everywhere yeah
colitis
all these oh yeah here's the one hhs
says
in 1940 six percent of americans had
chronic diseases
so the entire universe of all those
diseases that i just mentioned
only six percent of americans so they
existed
existed it was 1940 there was already
chemicals there was already vaccines you
know one vaccine really
and there was chemicals but they existed
and that's probably close
to a background level of what society
ought to look like yeah okay by 1986
it had risen to 12.8 um
double wasn't done more than noble and
then
by 2006
it was 54 can you imag
oh it's half our kids are disabled yes
and nobody's saying anything about it
tony fauci is not
you know this is this dwarfs coronavirus
so let me let me just repeat that you're
saying 54
2006 hh has its own data so more than
one out of two kids born
will have one has a chronic disease
lifetime
lifetime chronic disease it's
unfathomable
we got so much more to talk about but
first let's check out some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
hey this is jane in los angeles i used
to have a lot of trouble making
decisions
and now whenever i go out to eat and i'm
looking at a menu i get
five seconds to pick and making quick
fast decisions has helped me get better
and more comfortable with making
decisions in other parts of my life
hi guys i'm brittany originally from
montana now living in new york
i wanted to call because you guys speak
a lot about intention well i believe
that attention is important when buying
i also think we should use intention
when we're decluttering
for example i'm a huge movie fan and
recently got rid of over 60 dvds
instead of dropping them off at the
thrift store to be sold i donated them
all to my local library
like so my boyfriend was finally ready
to give up his xbox so we found a local
shelter that frequently has children
and we donated the games and consoles to
them while it does create a few extra
trips your things
can really create value for someone else
if you let them by the way we have a
bunch more
surprise questions this week like ryan
is there such thing as
healthy competition also
when does it make sense to not trust the
science
we're also going to talk to rfk about
being banned and censored
we're going to talk about thought crimes
we're going to talk about apologizing
and a whole bunch of other controversies
we're going to go deep on this one plus
we're going to answer a million more
questions controversial questions and if
you want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app it is cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it's really where we get intimate
where we go deep
um trying to think of other synonyms or
going deep right
real mature penetrating this is really
where we
no it's too far
this is really where we get naked and
make love wait what
idea love oh i do oh my bad yeah
idea sex i've heard someone call it yeah
so no
what we do we do talk about some things
we don't talk about in public we do that
on
the private podcast the minimalists.com
support you can follow the minimalists
on facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
for event information while you're there
you can also sign up for our email list
to get our podcast show notes and
minimalist writings
sent straight to your inbox if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com and if you leave here
today with just one message let it be
this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time